*clap* Ah, there we are.
So we have diagnostic information here, but we can also get a
3D view of what the Hololens actually sees.
So this is the point cloud and or rather mesh that it's creating in real-time.
As you can see that's the room was standing in.
There's the table.
That's the point of view of the Hololens in real time.
First-person view.
There is a bit of a delay.
The Hololens does not need a cable of any sort.
It's all on board.
This is just to give a preview,
otherwise it's really laggy over Wi-Fi.
*BLIP*BLIP*DIT*DIT*DIT*DIT*DIT*DIT*DIT*
Point it at me. Let's have a look at what I look like with this.
So, can you be seen? Because it might...
Because you're effectively a dynamic mesh,
it might not be tracking you.
-Are you actually showing up?
-Eh..something's there.
Maybe. Let's see if I update it...
And uh, give it a...
-Ah! Is there...
-Yes, something is there.
Okay.
Yep, and that is enough information for the Hololens to say
-"Right, there is some sort of object there."
-I can sort of see my camera there...
-Yep.
-Because I'm pointing at the laptop
-that's on the table.
-Alright
Do we have a...?
-Hold on, let's...
-Trying to stay still
Okay, and I'll just tell it to update the mesh.
-Ah!
-There we are.
So this is basically a depth map of me is it?
Pretty much, yeah.
Well from this angle only.
I'll have to walk around otherwise.
I'm seeing some blinking red lights on you.
That is the depth camera array that's on the top of the Hololens, very similar to a Kinect's,
so the exact cocktail of sensors
is not very well known.
Talking to you now,
I can sort of just see your eyes,
but it feels like I've walked
a bit into the future here.
Indeed it is.
Of all the various head mounts we have,
this one is probably
the more Star Treky of the lot.
-Haha
-Yeah
Just like the Kinect or
the Tango and all those devices,
What it's doing is
reading the environment around it,
which is different from what, say
normal optical AR does.
And by creating a measure to understand the environment around it.
And we can start placing content there
So, as you can see that's
the example of the mesh,
what it's seeing.
The mesh it's creating in real time.
-Is it constantly updating that?
-All the time.
It's reading the environment
all the time,
and now this is a view,
exactly what I see.
So I can populate the world
around me with any
visual contact I want.
So this is the menu, basically.
You should be able to it.
There we are.
So that is a hologram in space.
So let's go play some other stuff.
For example, my settings.
I can either place it in space,
just leave it there,
or I can go find a nice flat surface
like say, side of this printer,
and place it.
And that is now locked that that's where it
belongs
So, that is now a normal Windows 10 menu,
many of you will probably
have seen it before.
There we are.
Or we can start placing
other stuff.
Let's place a...
It's a theme we put around
three lines.
-These demos usually.
-So that is now locked onto
the table.
It won't however, it won't move.
It is there.
Now the key thing here unlike most
of the other AR solutions
we have seen is
as soon as these sensors have an
understanding of depth,
they can deal
with the occlusion problem.
So the occlusion problem is where
the...any AR solution
doesn't exactly know what it's looking at.
Now, so, and in which case it
draws the digital content above
everything,
so if you've used any AR,
any mobile phone-based AR
with a marker,
you have probably tried putting your
hand in front of the marker
to see if it occludes
the virtual content or
if anybody tries to
pick stuff up.
Normally, with marker-based AR,
that simply won't work.
All it can really do is tie
content that marker,
but in this case it,
does have a sense of depth,
so it can effectively read
your hand
and stop drawing content over it,
so if I put my
hand over the cat, right
you can see now
it is not working
because it hasn't
triggered from my hand just yet,
but it will eventually catch on.
If you went and kinda looked
behind this laptop,
- will the cat disappear behind this laptop?
- Uh, it should.
Assuming the the device has actually
read the laptop.
Let's have a go.
Oh, that is stuck.
- Does the stickiness
happen quite often or is it..?
- No, it's only for the preview
really.
- Oh so basically it's
because we're looking on the laptop
- Indeed, it's a little bit of a debug view.
As far as my experience goes
on the Hololens,
everything is smooth.
Oh, there we are.
So, let's have a look.
So it looks like we don't have a lot of
occlusions here.
No, my laptop doesn't seem to
want to hide it.
The problem with the room here
is there's not a lot of stuff
to hide behind.
So let's try something else.
So, if I was to take a another
hologram and place it
behind something like sit on the floor
over here.
Right.
There we are, I can see the dog
and now the table's in the way.
Can't see it.
- Yeah, ok.
- Yep so, this is a case where the geometry
has been correctly read,
so the Hololens is sure
that that is a static feature
in my environment.
So it now has built geometry.
As we saw before actually,
we can switch back to
the previous view.
There we are.
So, this is the geometry
that it is using for the occlusion.
- Oh, so you can see that table there...
- Yep.
-and it's not perfectly smooth.
- Exactly, so previously the cat
could not be hidden
behind the laptop because
as you can see, the laptop
is shown up as a short mesh.
If I had kept moving,
it probably would have hidden it.
The table though is a nice solid
object.
(it's got that)
and the dog is hiding
hiding behind the table,
so I can see the
hologram from here.
you probably cannot on
the screen now because
we're seen the preview.
But as I move and I'm
behind the table, it's hidden.
This has not systematically
scanned the entire room
- and got geometry exactly.
- Mhm
So, are we looking at a trade-off with that?
Yes. Yes. Seeing as this is an entirely
on-board process,
so unlike say,
all the virtual reality headsets
we've seen, this does not
require a desktop computer.
It's basically mobile phone strapped
to my face, just like the Tango.
There is continuously a trade-off between
speed and performance,
so if you want to maintain
the experience that everything is smooth,
say about 30 frames per second for all the content
I'm seeing,  it's going
to start cutting corners.
and it also goes down to the basically the capabilities
of the sensors.
How much granularity can they pick up.
How much detail, so you'll see that
they kind of tend to cut corners,
will ignore clatter on the tables.
They're not very good with
see through surfaces,
so for example, the glass walls
over here as you can see,
they will simply not register.
Because it all comes down
to computer vision in this case,
but computer vision on the sensors.
Just like we have seen with
other AR stuff when
it's through a some sort
of glass case or what-have-you.
The cameras actually see the reflections,
but unlike our brains,
they did not know to discard them.
So they don't really know
what to do with them.
The depth sensors so in this case,
I see straight through them.
So that is both a good
thing and a bad thing,
depending on your on how
you want to apply it
So, I could place a hologram there, but it
wouldn't necessarily see it as a wall.
So, let's see what we can do.
Of course it's not all
just placing Holograms around
Right off the bat, it's the idea that
you can use the environment around you
as you're, well, computer environment,
so if you could just transplant your
everyday desktop use into the
environment.
So I can place a Word file over there,
I can put my browser on my ceiling,
make a massive screen.
Eh, obviously there are a lot of uses
in entertainment, so the games
on this thing are pretty good.
They will use the environment,
you can use the physics of your-
the environment around you.
So you can have a ball bounce,
on the table,
bounce on the floor.
People have tried this kind of gesture-based
and moving around kind of
interfaces for computing before
And it doesn't really seem to take off.
People are quite comfortable
with a keyboard and a mouse,
or some kind of trackpad.
Indeed.
Weirdly, this is probably the first
examples where I've seen people
just click with it.
So it's only really got to gestures that recognizes,
the click and the menu,
but that is enough.
It is. It is enough for you to be
able to do basic interaction such as
drag stuff around, scroll around, select things
in a way you normally might, you know,
pointing at something is a
is a normal interaction
and translates quite well.
And it's the it's also reliability factor,
so one of the reasons these
things don't catch on
Is because usually don't work.
They have a, you know,
you're sitting there tapping
things, this one is just registering
and working quite well.
The two gestures for example, the the bloom
"my bloom" it's called,
just works reliably every time.
Same as the other main interaction which is the
click, so I'm not, well there we go.
Every time I click,
we get a update of the mesh.
You can see how it's
reading the mesh there,
the environment around it.
Or if I want to get rid of windows,
just point out what I want
and remove.
There, we do have a bit of a problem.
Yes, I can select things and there are
two gestures that work very reliably,
but what were missing is a cursor.
Yes, I do have a cursor in
the middle of like a,
like a crosshair in the
middle of my view.
But that means I'm relying on the
direction of my head in order to
basically look at something,
center it in the middle of my screen
and then select it.
Um, this is a good and bad thing.
There are various interaction methods to do this,
maybe, I could point at something.
But you see that pointing is actually not
one of the most accurate things in the world.
We have some other studies with
other interfaces where you can see that
people think they're pointing at something
but really they're pointing
with an arm,
they're pointing with a wrist,
they're pointing with a finger.
So, getting a system that understands
the intent of the user is pretty difficult,
but gaze is pretty solid.
We have a crosshair,
we aim at we want
- we select it.
- We're seeing a preview here
which is a camera on the
front of the device in this view.
Is your field of view a lot wider than that?
Can you see more stuff?
If you're looking at that cat,
what can you see at the sides
- of your arms?
-That is a very good question.
That's actually one of the
things that well surprises
most people when they put this on.
The field of view is actually that narrow.
view is actually fat narrow,
unlike pretty much every headset just right now.
This is a proper heads-up display,
meaning it's not like the Google Glasses
where I have my real vision and then a
second window up in the corner, giving me a
version of the real world.
This is directly adding content to my normal
vision
The problem is the area that it has to
add this content is really very narrow.
I think that's the equivalent of a
15-inch screen at normal distance,
so really my field of view of augmented
content and it sounds bad, but it's not
that bad, is really just this angle over here.
- It's really narrow.
- But you can see at the sides, can you?
Uh, yes. Yes I can see.
It's all perfectly clear, so I can
see the cat now.
It's in the center of my
vision, but if I move my head ever so
slightly, at this point, the cat is
outside my augmented field of view.
It is quite narrow, but this is a technology
limitation that my understanding is has
already been overcome. It's again a
trade-off between cost and performance.
These are developer kits after all,
so they're already pretty pricey.
If they were to
have a proper field of you, probably the
weight and power requirements would have
made them quite unwieldy other time.
You know, the launch works very well.
It's Cortana.
- So umm...
- Should we try and put it on the camera?
-Yep.
- Let's see if this works.
- Okay, so...Whoops.
- It's not gonna work on b[oth]
- I'll have to look out through one
- of the eyes I guess.
- Oh yeah yeah.
- Oh. Hold on. Yep, I see content.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, there we are.
- Oh, Okay.
- Okay, so uh
- So, do you want to hold that against there?
- Yep, aim on other account.
Ok, then we-
- sure enough, there's content.
- Mhm.
- There's more content.
- Is the cat still there?
- Yeah there's...
Oh hold on, I'm doing it now.
- Uh, we move forward.
- Oh, there we go.
- Yeah it's quite interesting to see that line,
isn't it?
So, if I put this on the cat's nose
for instance,
and then what?
Click or something?
- Yep. So, whenever you can interact with
something, the dot will turn into a circle.
- Ah, okay
- Indeed. And also, when it sees
fingers and it says
"Okay, you're ready to click."
Same thing.